The Star Wars franchise is about to venture
into territory previously uncharted, but is
the high-stakes mission a hit or a miss?
General audiences won't be able to tune into
the first-ever live-action Star Wars series,
The Mandalorian, until it hits the upcoming
streaming site Disney+ on November 12.
But a number of lucky critics have already
gotten the chance to catch about a half hour's
worth of footage from the show during a special
Disney event held on October 19.
Taking to social media, these critics have
spilled their spoiler-free thoughts on The
Mandalorian, and things are looking brighter
than C-3PO after a buff and shine.
"Die, Jedi dogs!
What did I say?"
In fact, many have praised the forthcoming
series everything they had hoped for...and
then some.
Here's a round-up of the first reactions to
The Mandalorian.
One of the biggest takeaways from the early
reactions to The Mandalorian is that it's
kick-ass, action-packed, and basically everything
a Star Wars fan could want from a live-action
series.
From what critics have seen so far, it sounds
like the set pieces, aesthetic, characters,
and story of the show all come together to
make for a series that fans of the franchise
will love.
Collider editor in chief Steven Weintraub
said in his reaction,
"This is the Star Wars thing I've been waiting
for!
While I love the Skywalker saga, I've wanted
to see new characters and places explored
in depth which can only be done over multiple
episodes in a series format.
Cannot wait to see more."
He continued,
"It's as awesome as you want it to be.
Can't say anything specific but one scene
answered a question that I don't think has
ever been explained/shown in any Star Wars
movie.
Love that it opens up the Star Wars universe
in a cool new way."
Star Wars social media manager Michelle Buchman
tweeted her prediction that fans will be very
pleased by the Jon Favreau-created series,
which she said reminded her of
"...old studio westerns of the 40's and 50's
with a dash of samurai movie vibes mixed in
a Star Wars-y blender."
Actress and host Jennifer Larda felt similarly,
writing,
"...all I have to say is, this is the epic
Star Wars show we’ve been waiting years
for.
Please pardon my excitement."
She then clarified that she has nothing but
love for the animated Star Wars series that
have come before, like The Clone Wars, Rebels,
and Resistance.
But if you've been holding out hope for a
live-action series, The Mandalorian is the
answer to your prayers.
Entertainment Tonight producer and online
host Ash Crossan was moved to tears after
watching footage from The Mandalorian, signaling
that the series is powerful enough to make
viewers incredibly emotional given its quality
and its true-to-Star Wars feel.
She tweeted after the exclusive screening
event,
"Just watched 27 minutes of Mandalorian footage
and legit cried.
Can't say much but, This is real and it's
happening and it feels SO FREAKING STAR WARS."
Drew Taylor, former managing editor at Moviefone
and current co-host of the podcasts Light
the Fuse and Fine Tooning, was totally blown
away by The Mandalorian, for a different reason.
For Taylor, the best part of the footage he
saw was its twist: apparently, the character
played by Nick Nolte isn't who fans might
think he is.
Taylor wrote in a two-tweet thread on Twitter,
"Wow.
The Mandalorian is completely amazing.
Saw nearly a half hour of footage from what
I was told were the first three episodes.
Whoever you think Nick Nolte is...the answer
will surprise you.
Also it looks as expensive as it is, they
didn't skimp with this one.
Spaceships, creatures, etc all in full effect.
Cannot wait for full episodes."
Eric Goldman of Get Fandom praised The Mandalorian
as being both very cool and very atmospheric,
with Pedro Pascal's titular character having
what it takes to immediately captivate audiences.
"What is it like to be the Mandalorian?"
"Well, just look at the image.
That's what it's like!"
He also compared the series to a couple of
action-heavy films that he's a fan of, writing,
"[It's] sometimes evoking the vibe of Rogue
One (which I adore).
The title character is instantly fascinating
and there are great action and suspense moments,
including some Predator vibes."
"Come on.
Kill me, I'm here!
Kill me!"
Award-winning writer and Rotten Tomatoes-approved
critic Rosie Knight gave perhaps the coolest
and most promising take on The Mandalorian
when she tweeted,
"Reliving my childhood Saturday mornings watching
Star Wars.
The 30 [or] so minutes of The Mandalorian
footage we saw was incredibly cool.
The samurai-infused space western you've always
wanted with an ice cold lead, a bunch of rad
creatures, and a killer score."
IndieWire critic Tyler Hersko tweeted that
The Mandalorian exceeded expectations, and
should serve as a major hit for Disney+ thanks
to its high production value.
He wrote,
"I just got out of the Mandalorian press screening
and gotta say, really surpassed expectations.
This seems like a truly high-budget, movie-like
project.
If other flagship Disney+ series have a similar
production quality, the streaming service
will definitely have a strong run."
Added Screen Rant features editor Mansoor
Mithaiwala,
"Saw almost 30 minutes of The Mandalorian
footage this morning.
It's truly incredible.
It looks like the films, feels innately Star
Wars, introduces new concepts, and adds layers
that people have been waiting to see for a
long time."
Audiences at home can witness The Mandalorian
in all its apparent glory when it hits the
Disney+ platform on November 12th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.